let's talk obesity
let's talk obesity
new story tyler has that for you from
the post millennial we can put that up
on the screen as we go along tick tocker
blasts small ranch for saying she's
above the weight limit to ride their
horses
so this tick tocker she has a lot of
followers she has two million followers
on tick tock no small feet that's her in
the photo that's the ranch pictured
her name is remy bader hopefully i'm
saying that correctly
she blasted a small horse ranch in
montauk that's in long island in new
york for telling her she was above the
weight limit to ride their horses and
what she did is she put on tick tock a
video of the ranch and she said shout
out to deep hollow ranch in montauk for
making me leave because i weigh over
240. that's apparently her weight as she
revealed
the video that she posted has over 1.6
million views i'm sure it's even beyond
that at this point this is last i
checked and it has a lot of commentators
comments on there harassing the small
business
however you also have people on there
i'm reading from the article still that
noted the potential negative health
effects on the horse for carrying these
obese riders
so i don't know a lot about horses um
that's not my expertise that's not my
specialty what i do know is what i
googled and when i saw this
i immediately went and said okay is
there a risk here and you imagine that
there would be you know a horse can can
only carry so much weight so what what
is going on here and when you google it
you find out that yes in fact it is a
fact that horses can only carry a
certain amount of weight so she was
upset
and the question is what did she expect
to happen here right
what did she expect to happen she felt
bad because she the reality is this is a
reality this is not me being judgmental
she is obese she is overweight right
this is a reality you can look at the
photo this is a fact okay that's not
good for her it's not healthy for her
it's up to her it's her own decision to
make in life how she wants to live her
life of course but
the fact is is that she is overweight
and the ranch is not there to protect
her feelings the ranch is not there to
make her feel good her me tyler anyone
not to make us feel good about ourselves
not to give us an ego boost when we show
up and say come on down do whatever you
want with the horses no the ranch is
there to protect the horses to make sure
that they're being cared for properly to
make sure that they're not in danger
that's their policy whether it's a man a
woman whoever shows up that's their
policy
so it's interesting to me that she went
on the attack i immediately thought of
my child and i said well
if i decided that i wanted to take
hartley to an amusement park and hartley
said
i want to go on the roller coaster
and he walked up and there's that little
height requirement you know oh i hated
that growing up i always wanted to go on
the big the big girl rides
anyway you walk up to the height
requirement if you don't make it you
can't go on the ride there's not a
negotiation that happens there's not a
shaming of the amusement park that
happens you can't go on the ride because
it's unsafe why because you could if
you're too small you slip out and you
could die
in this case if you weigh too much
there's a chance that that horse could
be at risk if you go further in the
article actually
a couple of people weigh in on it who do
know about horses and this is what
happens is what they say the national
riding stables horse rescue a nonprofit
organization
notes advice from dr deb bennett phd who
says total weight of the rider plus tac
must not exceed 250 pounds there's no
horse alive of any breed any build
anywhere that can go more than a few
minutes with more weight on its back
than this
then john cardillo a conservative
commentator raises this point you could
cause internal injuries to the horse you
can cause spinal injuries to the horse
so this is just a matter of reality
right
why should what should the ranch have
done
what should they have done should they
have said you know what she's going to
be upset
so let's endanger the horses no of
course not but we live in a world now
where people feel like
my feelings come first
and you must acknowledge them respect
them and act accordingly
so she posted this and a whole bunch of
people shamed the ranch as if they were
supposed to make a separate set of rules
for her and we were supposed to pretend
that this would have been a safe
situation for the horses when the ranch
which knows their horses doesn't isn't
out to hurt people's feelings believe me
they would have rather had her come on
i'm sure they can charge for these
things i'm sure they would have rather
had her come on have been able to enjoy
the experience if they don't want you to
enjoy the experience of riding the
horses they wouldn't have a ranch and
offer that opportunity out to people
that's why they exist
so here's the blunt truth
if she wanted to ride that horse
she would there are two options she
would either have to lose weight and go
back and meet the rate requirement just
a fact i'm not getting involved in
feelings here this is just a fact or she
would have to say okay
i don't meet the way requirement i'm
comfortable with how i am
this is who i am
i guess i can't engage in this activity
end of story and not play a victim and
not try to harass and not try to make it
like they were out to get her if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]
you